what's important uh uh for us at
tpy is really to partner with the
founders
who are radically open-minded like we
you sense
you sense that at the very first uh
moment someone
you know steps through the door or uh
gets in front of you on
on zoom whether the person is a radical
open-minded person or someone that comes
with a very well thought
you know well-established theory of what
needs to happen when and uh
and how welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillel stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i am joined today by decal percy
a founding partner at tpua capital an
early stage venture capital fund with
over 135 million dollars under
management
tpy capital partners with both serial
and first-time entrepreneurs
seeking partners who share similar
values and hands-on support
tpy capital invested in more than 20
companies including ai 21
unipass h2 pro kedma pascal paramount
data
tab 9 signals sibo and
decal percy welcome to 20 minute leaders
tpy how are you doing
thank you very much uh happy to be here
doing very well
i'm honored to have you here there's so
many things that i want to talk about
your journey
from your upbringing in iran to hedge
funds to private equity to cfo of a
family office and then
and most recently now a founding
founding partner of tpy
so many different things around the
financial world
within tpy quantum computing and fintech
i don't even know where to begin so
take me back to iran take me back a
little bit about your upbringing
how does one get to grow up to be so
successful in so many different
financial institutions
in the tech world now yeah so
uh i i was born in jerusalem and found
myself
actually when i was uh uh six years old
as a
child in the the biggest expat community
of back then
uh outside the region that was the iran
there were 20 000 israelis
at that time some of them were actually
involved in
in building the iranian civil nuclear
program it was an israeli venture
and i went to an israeli school uh in
tehran
uh israel
israeli school in tehran yeah i i do
even today i get to meet like
people which i've never known you know
of their existence and they said what
iran yeah i
we went to the same school so it
happened to me last uh
last week actually from someone who was
based out of la
uh yeah and then back to uh uh
to israel and like many veterans of the
uh the iranian uh
uh expat community uh to my father
uh spent some time in in africa many
israelis moved to uh that was the
silicon valley of
uh of the 80s uh
back to israel military service out with
a stint in the caribbean
uh in between and joined the military
um and actually during my military
service that was the the
the first time i got exposure into the
world of
uh investing and and decision making so
i was crunching numbers
on an as400 back then uh 1991
military leaders yeah it's a it's a
computer and it's
actually still uh some organizations are
still using using them using it
right uh yeah so so i was you know
crunching numbers to
to help the leaders make better
decisions
around you know r d or you know are we
buying
you know more planes or more tanks or
like what's the
the trade-off versus uh certain
scenarios so that was my first kind of
glimpse into the world of uh risk
uh management and when i left the mirror
today i joined
what was then the nascent israeli uh uh
itec
uh software company i joined the company
who was
i think one of the first ipos ever at
nasdaq that was in 1996 company was
selling erp systems for uh for hospitals
and the first client was stella schomer
hospital yeah so that and then um i
moved from
uh to the other side to the investment
side and i joined a fund
but back then um the term vc was not
even
coined that was an investment house and
we did like many other funds you know
everything from
investing in in kibbutzim owned plastic
and metal
uh companies uh all the way through
uh new high-tech
company so we had a portfolio of about
25 investments
you know some of the names you may know
like tommy alba
you know the famous israeli that was my
first investment
uh great investment by the way i exited
to
south uh all the way through medical
device
you know uh one of the first israeli
medical device company called versamed
it was acquired by uh by ge
and then and then came you know the
dot-com bubble
and the first intifada or the second i
i lost count uh and
and the dot-com bubble so and the uh
sorry in the uh
the 9-11 so i figured that's that's you
know a great timing to uh
to take a break and do my uh my mba so i
i moved uh
to europe for a one year mba program
uh you know i left with a with a
backpack and i got back to israel
12 years later with two full load
containers a wife and three kids so
that was the the one one-year mba
amazing
so you're in europe and tell me a little
bit you know what i'm hearing a common
thread here is this idea of being able
to identify interesting opportunities
both for yourself
and you know in terms of timing but also
in terms of understanding
where where the market is shifting and
where you can continue your own personal
learning curve to continue
understanding the the financial world
better
where we ended now after you know in
europe and you're part of a family
office tell me tell me more about about
this part of the journey
and then i want to get to tpy yeah so i
i finished my mba i wanted to stay uh in
europe
uh it was a difficult time uh in the job
market
so i figured hey i'm going to stay with
the with the fund i was
with back time and going to help you
know some of the portfolio companies
uh do business in the uh
in the european uh union right and that
led me to uh
to uh almost a random uh meeting
with what later became my anchor uh
lp or my founding investment
partner uh started as you know
discussions around the world the world
is going and and investments and so on
and uh after a few a few uh months of
conversations i found myself uh as a
full-time
employee of that uh family business and
based out of belgium luxembourg perry's
uh exciting
environment to work with and
i had exposure to many different
industries you know from
luxury to diamonds to manufacturing
to alternative assets spending time
you know from india to japan singapore
uh traveling great
great time amazing before you realize
you know suddenly you have family and
kids and then you start to think okay
uh what identity i want my kids to
you know to grow up and it was clear to
me that
i want them to be israelis okay uh and
when my
daughter started to respond to me in in
netherlands and in in french
i said okay stop going back uh to israel
uh and it was it was obvious i want to
do something in the investment uh
sector i managed to convince my uh my
employer to back
to back me up uh you know with a search
fund
who later involved into a single lp fund
who later
evolved into a multi-lpa fund which is
what was it like coming back 23 years
later to a
a nation that is 12 years old to a
nation that is
very it's still very very different 12
years is a long time
yeah yeah well i wasn't absent for 12
years because i used to come at least uh
four times uh
a year which was a fantastic uh
experience to come back to my
you know home country as a tourist it's
an amazing uh
opportunity uh but yeah you you realize
that
uh you know i've i've been sleeping in
europe you know in dormant europe
while israel has been you know moving at
the speed of flight so uh
it was great like to uh uh to be back
uh you know it's also a sense of uh
like closing the loop on uh
on some personal ambitions you know to
live uh
outside of israel i've done that been
there i don't want to move anymore
that's
my home that's my place and that's where
i'm going to start well that's
the rest of my life leading to you now
helping run a leading israeli venture
capital fund for early stage companies
both pre-revenue and revenue stage
tpy and within there you're looking at
quantum computing in fintech
and you know one of the things that that
we'll talk about in a second it's this
idea of relationship building
with founders and and the way that the
fund is working but before we get to
that
you've spent so many years doing all
sorts of investments
you know when i'm growing up to this
world of investments really the only
thing that i know is
venture capital and and the way that
it's working and and it's hard for me to
even imagine a different way of working
what is it like for you now balancing
you know
the mindset of venture capital but but
you're used to i guess different speeds
different types of companies right
right so you know i think
what what's true for entrepreneurs and
also for investors
uh and actually it's it's almost a
scientific uh
fact you have to adapt like if you want
to survive you have to adapt
circumstances you have to adapt to
change of
speeds and exchange of of landscape and
i think that was you know like part of
my upbringing you know to be one day
in africa hot and then you know
a few months later in in switzerland and
like the shift from you know hot and
stinking to
white and beautiful and you have to uh
to adapt yourself
to the environment i mean that's part of
my uh my dna and that's what i'm trying
to bring into uh
everything that i do like move on if
things don't
you know look uh good if the
environmental change there's a new
competitor
uh there's uh
a new technology that is uh you know
underpinning your uh your plans just
you know read the reality deal with it
and move on i love it
okay tpy tell me about tpy
right
so
tell me about tpy so yeah tpy so i
started tpy
uh with my partner my my beloved partner
uh guy uh that was back in in um
2011 so as i mentioned it started as as
a search fund
evolved into a single lp um
investment arm and then evolved into a
multi-lp
uh fund which is the the the current
fund
we we we started really you know with an
open-minded
uh attitude like where where are the
opportunities and and
in the first fund we kind of you know
sampled or
uh tasted several uh verticals all the
way from
from foodtech that was one of our most
successful uh
investments in a company called the
enzymotec
uh which i'm very proud of actually one
of the uh
best israeli communists founded by by an
israeli arab
uh which connects to another theme of
our our fund which is
diversity uh all the way through ad tech
and uh and uh data and analytics and
that was kind of you know we're setting
the stage for
uh our current finding py2 where we
decided to focus on certain
uh verticals so we are as vertical
agnostic
uh fun but we do have our uh preferences
one of them is
as you mentioned quantum computing which
i found a fascinating
subject all the way to cloud uh
infrastructure data and analytics
uh and a bucket which we call human
augmentation so everything that helps
humans do things uh better faster
incredible so obviously
you're bringing with you a wealth of
experience from
from the financial sectors looking at
different markets understanding the
world being adaptive
being empathic to all sorts of different
people and societies and and colleagues
around the world
when you're looking at now at the
israeli ecosystem and you're coming in
with a with tpy fun one and now fun too
how how are you strategically thinking
about this in your day-to-day because
you've done a lot of the financial side
night there's a lot of also work with
the actual entrepreneurs besides just
the investment right
right well i i think the the
the best is yet to come for israel as a
as a nation and for the uh
israeli uh high-tech sector like you
know i've seen the sector growing from
uh
from a very small software companies you
know where a 40 million dollar exit was
considered an amazing and and a 10
million dollar pro
ipo proceeds at nasdaq was an amazing
success uh
and now we're in a totally different uh
uh stage
of uh scale uh
but there there's a lot to do in other
uh
in other verticals like israel today you
know the high tech sector is probably
you know 80 percent is focused around uh
cyber
and uh and fintech there's a lot to do
in uh in life sciences in
other areas and and that depends you
know primarily on
the the nation's ability to produce more
uh engineers and uh and uh talent so
that's
not kinda 20 000 feet overview of
where we're heading uh i think also that
the uh the fact that we're in a nation
that
is constantly under uh you know
stressors
uh exogenic uh stressors again it's
i often take analogies from nature
because i love observing uh
nature you know a muscle or a bone
gets you know stronger as a response to
uh
to stress and that's also true for uh
uh for societies uh not that i'm wishing
uh
our our nation to um eternally
uh face the the troubles that that we
have but i think the
part of the culture uh and uh the fact
that we have to you know to go through
cycles
of existential uh threats every once in
a while is
is the unique recipe for uh right
it's kind of just existence and balance
to think through those
existential crises and these cycles is
actually motivators and catalysts for
for what we're seeing with with the
economy going and i think that's pretty
remarkable
when you're sitting down with the with
the entrepreneurs
pre or post investment and you're
thinking through the journeys
what what is your perception of this so
what is your perception of the
relationship that you're building with
them
and and and what is your role in
collaborating with them as you go on
yeah uh so first of all i know i can
offer only my very limited
uh point of view because i do think you
know
every every fund manager is going
through an uh you know adverse selection
process where
you end up you know teaming up with
like-minded
uh entrepreneurs and what's important uh
uh for us at tpy is really to partner
with the
founders who are radically open-minded
like we you sense you sense that at the
very first
uh moment someone you know steps through
the door
or uh gets in front of you on uh on uh
zoom whether
the person is a radical open-minded
person or someone that comes with a very
well thought
you know well-established theory of what
needs to happen
when and uh and how and you know what we
often
what we often say to entrepreneurs is
that you know if you come to us for
for answers you know go look for another
partner like i'm not smarter than uh
than you are i can only offer you uh
questions very good questions uh by the
way
that's gonna you know help you challenge
your belief
that's gonna help you you know find a
white spot
in your thinking or uh or a new
opportunity
and i love it that's you know sort of my
our attitude was uh working with
entrepreneurs
asking the right questions and already i
already managed to mention this to you
know when i when i was preparing for
this episode i was looking at your
wrestling and i was looking through some
of the materials
and and it it felt it felt very very
welcoming it felt very different it felt
very much more of a partnership it
didn't feel uh you know the the
traditional
venture capital that that i think a lot
of vcs are going in this direction now
and i think that's pretty exciting
from an entrepreneurial perspective and
that that this this is the sort of
partnership that we're heading to
and decade i really want to thank you
for coming and for sharing your story
and your time i have a few last
questions back to you
and i want to take you back to your
childhood before before your your
crunching numbers
on the on the computer that i already
forgot the name of the computer from the
army
what fascinates you as a kid what really
drives you
in your day-to-day yeah so i
i think i know i became a venture
capitalist or our investor
uh because i couldn't become a scientist
like that was my childhood uh dream
i was fascinated by uh by science
astronomy i mean i still find myself uh
on a weekly basis between midnight and 2
a.m you know watching astronomy uh
the documentaries and physics uh
documentaries
and so i think this you know basic
curiosity to like you know
where we come from what are we made of
where are we uh we're heading there with
questions that
pre-occupied me as as a as a kid
life events you know kind of uh life
dynamics
led me to uh to a career in finance and
investing
uh but i remain this uh you know
frustrated
scientist or frustrated uh engineer
and the second best is you know to
actually work with
with scientists and engineers so i
really really like uh you know
doing it
uh and yeah you know when when you know
thinking of
things like quantum computing uh and you
know just the idea that you know things
can
you know coexist at the same time like
truth
and and false can coexist you know and
it kind of resonates with everything
i've been uh you know learning
uh to my career there's no single truth
there's no
zero or one you know zero and one can
coexist you know
two conflicting beliefs can coexist and
be
true at the same uh at the same time
amazing um amazing well i think that
that's a perfect segue to the next
question about you and
what inspires you today
um so yeah i think when when you see the
the pace of uh scientific discoveries
the pace of uh innovation
it preoccupies me it also concerns me
because i think we are
you know might be innovating ourselves
to uh extinction
that's you know uh
right now absolutely uh
but i at the same time i think you know
uh innovation and progress cannot be
uh stopped like there's nothing right in
uh
in our power to stop it and that's you
know probably where uh
uh where we're heading and
generally speaking i think you know the
world we live in today with
with all the uh the negative
aspects and global warming and wars it
is a better place
than what used to be uh you know 100
years ago so i'm a big believer in
innovation and progress and three last
questions uh three last words that you
would choose for yourself
three words which is for yourself yeah
well
uh first of all a father i yeah i'm i'm
uh
a 100 father in my personality and my
uh my being i can see
i'm i'm a curious uh person
and and i'm a long-term thinker which is
maybe another way to say a dreamer
i love it
your portfolio michael the companies are
so so interesting and and i really thank
you for taking the time
and and i look forward to to continue
building the relationship and then get
and picking your brain on some ideas
of my own soon rather than later same
here and looking forward to hosting you
in our offices